-Lucy, we love you.
Thanks for coming
back to the show.
-It's so great
to see you guys again.
-Um, do you --
I was going to ask you,
and this is a real question.
-Okay.
-Because I follow you
on socials,
and Instagram and stuff.
Do you --
you've been all over the world.
Do you know where
you are right now?
[ Laughter ]
-I just got in last night,
so, no, I don't know.
I don't know what time it is --
-Weren't you just in Italy?
-This is perfect.
-Weren't you just in Italy,
I just saw --
-Yeah, I was in --
we were in Rome.
We went to London.
I was in Toronto --
-Wow.
-L.A.
-Everything.
And now you're going right back
to L.A.
-And then I go back to L.A.
for the premiere,
which will be exciting.
-Thank you for being here
on our show.
-No, I'm so happy it worked out.
-We appreciate it.
How is everything --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you.
I want to talk about the movie,
but how's Rockwell?
How's the baby?
-Oh, he's 7.
He's 7.
-No, isn't that weird.
-Can you believe it?
He's a little man.
-I remember when, I mean,
he was just strapped to you.
-Yeah, he was, like,
a meat puff.
-Yeah, he's so cute.
You were saying that he got to
meet Helen Mirren,
Dame Hellen Mirren, who's in --
-No, this isn't just a meeting.
-Oh.
-This was like a meeting of the
minds and the heart.
-Wow.
-Yeah, so, I'm in my -- in my
trailer, and she's like,
"Oh, your son is here.
I want to come and meet him."
-Yeah.
-So she comes and -- I mean,
you don't have to do that,
by the way.
-No, of course not.
She's the best.
-She's the best.
-Yeah, she's cool.
-So she comes in and sits down
in the trailer with him for
like, I don't know,
15, 20 minutes.
Just talks to him,
spends some time with him.
And then she's like,
"Oh, I've got to go get ready."
So she leaves and then he turns
to me and he's like,
"mommy, do you know who
I'm going to marry?"
And I was like,
"where is this coming from?
Does, how does he even
know what that is?"
-Yeah.
-I'm like, "no, who?"
He's like, "Helen."
[ Laughter ]
And then I was like -- and I so
shocked, I was like,
"well, what if she's
already married?"
He was like,
"Then I'll just be her butler."
[ Laughter ]
I was like "oh, that's what
a husband is."
-Come on, that's a 7-year-old --
-A butler or a husband.
-Yeah, exactly.
-It was hysterical.
-He's so cute.
-But that's the --
-The effect?
-The effect she has on people.
-The Helen Mirren --
-She's just so present.
-Yeah, even babies want
to marry her.
-Oh, my -- He was 5!
-Five when he said that?
-So it's like, pure instinct.
-I love him.
I want to talk about this,
'cause it's going around
the Internet, and I want to get
your take on it.
Our pal, Drew Barrymore,
who we love --
-Yes.
-said last month that
she'd be up for making another
"Charlie's Angels"
if you and Cameron --
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you and Cameron
were up for it as well.
-Well that's no pressure.
I mean, it's -- let's just say,
guys, it's been 23 years.
-Has it really?
-Yes, it's been 23 --
it's a long time.
-but still, look, 23 years --
I mean, you still
look like a baby.
-No, I feel great.
But I just mean, it's going to
be a different iteration
of a "Charlie's Angels,"
I guess.
-Yeah, I don't know.
-But, you know,
I love them so much.
It'd be -- it would be really
fun to do anything with them.
But, like, I just -- it's so --
It seems like it was yesterday,
and it seems like it was so
far away at the same time.
You know, like, the wire work
and all the Kung Fu, and --
-Did you guys do Comic-Con
for that one too?
No, you didn't.
That's not Comic-Con.
-No, we did comic-con for
"Shazam!" which was insane.
I've never been in a theater
like that before.
-I was gonna say, like, 'cause I
know, yeah, for "Shazam!"
you have to go to Comic-Con.
But it's like -- well, you
get to go to comic-con.
-No, it's because it's
a DC movie, you know?
And they really expect it.
And they have a special trailer
and a preview just for the fans.
-What is it like?
-These are not fans.
I mean, I'm sure you kind of
know about this, but these are,
like, superfans.
-Yes.
-So, it sort of even predates
anything you could do
as a person, as an actor,
as anyone.
Because they know everything.
-Before you were even were in
the movie, they know your
character.
-No, they know the history of
all the characters,
the comic books,
the movies, all of it.
You know, and for me, like,
I grew up just reading
the comic books.
So, it's very different.
Like, all the things that are
out now, it's just insanely,
you know -- I mean, you just
can't match the CGI
and all the special effects.
-Well, this film, you're flying
on a dragon the whole time.
It's amazing.
But I mean, what --
-Yeah, the dragon
is the star, okay?
Because this -- like,
look how small I am here.
-No, I know.
-The dragon is like
the entire --
-But what are you actually
riding on?
This is a new technology?
-Yeah, this is
one of the first.
I was like a Guinea pig.
It was a --
a mechanism that was for cars.
-Yeah.
-And I would sit on this --
they put a seat there for me.
-And it was a rig, and I was
kind of attached to it
with a wire, and a seat,
the whole thing.
-So, like a mechanical bull?
-Yeah, so --
It was basically riding
a bronco.
And they had different speeds,
and it was connected
to a computer.
-Just like riding --
[ Laughter ]
-Woo!
A cowboy hat --
-Yeah, instead of the hat,
I had a crown.
Be like, "whoo-hoo!"
But it was amazing.
-And then they add in --
-But it was connected to the
camera,
it was connected to their
computer,
so they had really specific
ideas of what they wanted,
and they could repeat
the exact movement every time.
-It's fascinating.
They did such a great job.
-I can't --
-I would say go see this in --
-And this dragon
is made out of wood.
-Yeah, by the way.
-It doesn't even have scales.
It's wood, so it's different.
-But I would say go see it in
IMAX
because it's just beautiful.
-Oh, it's completely insane.
-Stunning.
And how do we set up the movie,
and who you play in "Shazam"?
-So, the movie is,
you know, these kids
that basically get these super
powers when they say, "Shazam."
And we come in, instead of as
superheroes,
we come in as goddesses.
-Yeah.
-So, it's Greek mythology.
-Yeah!
-Which is really cool.
So we come in, and we -- our
world is dying,
and we're the daughters
of Atlas.
So, we have to come back and
claim what's rightfully ours.
So, Rachel, Helen, and I --
Rachel, who I love so much --
we have decided that we are the
protagonists in our story.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause we've come to
save our world.
-Yeah, and so you're not --
yeah, you're the protagonist.
-Yeah, because everyone's like,
"You're the supervillains!"
We're like, "are we?"
-No.
In our heads --
[ Light laughter ]
That's not the way a villain --
-No.
We're, like, saving our world.
-Yeah, exactly.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lucy Liu in
"Shazam!: Fury of the Gods."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Inhaling deeply ]
[ Overlapping whispering ]
[ Grunts ]
♪♪
[ Alarm sounding ]
[ Shouting indistinctly ]
♪♪
-No, no.
-[ Grunts ]
♪♪
-Woo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lucy Liu, everybody!
"Shazam! Fury of the Gods" opens
in theaters and IMAX March 17th.
Lucy and I are doing something
fun after the break.
Stick around.